you get this 31 page script I assume
your first thought is how am I ever
gonna memorize all this dialogue I like
the idea that it was shortened and but
basically what it said was the dialogue
is not going to be a big part of this as
an actor I kind of enjoyed that because
it was a challenge that I was anxious to
meet but it didn't take long for JC and
I to to come together on this because I
think I think the word was trust it was
a trust by instinct cuz there's no time
to develop a relationship there was no
time to to research on what kind of a
guy he was because he seemed to be kind
of out of his mind you know and so I
thought well maybe that's a good thing
and it was yeah it was a fine line I
mean the first time we met there was
something you know 10 minutes into the
meeting you know I had prepared this
whole sort of presence you know hours
long presentation of why why he should
do the thing and there was something you
know those 31 pages did feel like the
movie they're written pretty much the
movie you just saw so I think you
understood there was a movie there but
he you know I'll never forget it he sort
of sat there he kind of patted his legs
kind of ten minutes into it and he said
I you know just wanted to make sure you
weren't totally insane and let's do this
you know I literally remember him saying
let's do this and at that point you know
for whatever reason he never questioned
anything that we were kind of sort of
the foundation of this it was like
rock-solid as to why he wanted to do it
and we just started moving kind of in
lockstep
I had my reasons for making the film but
I knew that this version of the movie
was sort of best left what you just saw
I really believe that was the strongest
version of the movie so you know I think
by the second or third week we started
to really come to grips where he
realized you know III have some pretty
specifics about who he is where he is
you know what kind of bodis on you
strangely that biography the boat kind
of Laden who the guy was and then it
became his opportunity to just go with
it and I think amazingly he did as an
actor is that is that liberating or
exciting to not have a very specific
roadmap to try to kind of figure it out
as you go along or to make it up as you
seem fit this is a an existential piece
where you'd you only know a few things
and the only things I really need to
know are one there was a family involved
that he's sorry that he tells them he
tried and they know he tried and that's
it and so from that point on I went to a
whole other place with it which was
that's all we need to know the rest of
it is going to be the part that allows
the audience to come into it because you
don't tell them too much and so I ended
up appreciating that that there's
tremendous detail that we you know the
detail that we spent every day going
into were sort of emotional transitions
within each scene which is something
that he can do you know I don't know how
he can but he can so that essentially we
would do you know an action and we'd
work through something then we say and
right here at this moment you know X is
going to happen and and fear turns to
perseverance or boredom turns to
god-awful fear or you know anger turns
to you know beauty and and all of those
moments which which I started to treat
like dialogue almost and he has an
amazing ability that he can turn on and
off which makes it even that much more
amazing where he's essentially was I
could change a note and say that that's
you know this isn't actually if you're
not panic-stricken right now you're
heading out there you know now what you
can do to fix this so that is switched
and he'd do another take and and it
would be clear as day right they are
non-verbally in front of you and so
those were the details that we zeroed in
on and I think
the sort of limited nature of the film
allowed that sort of journey to be
hopefully won the audience goes on him
with we it's a one-person movie so you
you don't have anybody else
to shoot if I you know if I hurt this
guy in any way so it was very stressful
on a lot of levels and and I think for
you know in it mirrored the stress of a
character in that case because unlike a
wild animal you know if you hurt
yourself out there that pretty much is
it you know you sort of seriously are
yourself there's you know it's the way
most wild creatures if they're not eaten
die you know and and so there was in a
weird way I loved that that was hanging
over the character's head because so so
we we played with taking risks but
trying to have them be calculated and
then I think you've said it so I'm not
saying that but you know then ego and
both of our egos start getting involved
and we both started to become more
comfortable with the surroundings and
then he started doing things that he
shouldn't have been what started was I
asked him when we met I said it's pretty
intense you know physical stuff what's
on your mind he said what we use used
for close-ups doubles I say okay so when
we got there because I was physical in
my life played sports and like to do my
own stunts when I could it was a kind of
an ego thing I want to do what I can
also as an actor you I always felt that
you should be as complete as you can be
as an actor therefore it isn't just a
talking head it's your whole body is
involved but you're not 20 anymore and
so I when we got there I think ego
kicked in my thought well let me see
give me let me take a shot at this you
know let me see if I can do it and when
he realized I could then he pushed me
further and then when he pushed me
further I go further next thing you know
we were all both in danger yeah
there's only one area that I asked him
to give me some something because I
trusted him so much and that was I
wanted I said JC we things are moving so
fast would you at least create some
moments for me to think because if I'm
so busy just dealing then we might be
missing something about the character of
being inside of himself and so when I
was a kid I grew up here in Los Angeles
in Santa Monica and as a kid we didn't
have much as a family so the only thing
I had was to go to the beach and I would
play along the shore and I would you
know surf and swim and do those things
but every now and then I'd lay back on
the beach and I'd look out I was just a
kid and I would look out and I would say
this ocean goes on it seems forever I
think if you keep going you're gonna go
to Japan and I thought wow so in my head
as a kid came the idea that this is a
vast vast thing this ocean when we were
on the boat when we were working I
thought you know the it's the most
unexplored part of our planet the ocean
and it's deep and it's dark gets darker
and darker as you go down and being
alone on the boat when a guy has a
moment just to contemplate or to take in
what's around him I thought what if he
could think about Here I am in the
middle of sort of nowhere and as far as
I can see it's just this vast stretch of
nothing but horizon and below me is a
vast stretch of deep deep deep miles of
deep water and I'm alone on that line
maybe if we just had a moment where you
could give me just a moment to pause and
just look out that's sort of where I
would go audience can go where they want
to go but at least it's a moment where
the guy at least every now and then just
contemplates what's there